jennifer lopez and ben affleck are no
strangers to a little pda
[Music]
and on tuesday the pair didn't hold back
as jlo left her man's house in brentwood
california and just me and it's good
it's great that's jen and ben
affectionately kissing in ben's driveway
and that's jen and ben after the 52 year
old triple threat attempted a playful
swat at ben's backside i'm thrilled i'm
really happy the batman vs superman star
looked casual in a gray t-shirt and
jeans while jen wore a black turtleneck
white high-waisted pants and strappy
black heels it feels really good and
it's really nice but i'm so happy the
couple celebrated the oscar winners 49th
birthday over the weekend
and jen took the time to also
acknowledge the actor's two daughters
fifteen-year-old violet and
twelve-year-old seraphina whom he shares
with his ex-wife jennifer garner a
source previously told et that the
hustlers star picked out gifts for the
girls necklaces featuring their birth
flowers and ben he's spending time with
her kiddos too jen shares 13 year old
twins max and emmy with her ex-hubby
mark anthony and a source told e.t last
week that jen ben and emmy had a fun
family night out at la hot spot craig's
quote everyone was getting along bonding
adding that they all seemed happy to be
there of course the couple famously
known as benifer recently rekindled
their romance 17 years after they called
it quits following her split from alex
rodriguez in april
e.t recently sat down with a former pro
baseball player who says despite facing
several high-profile setbacks including
his split from jen he's focusing on all
the positive things in his life right
now
i had uh five years of of an incredible
life and and partnership and also with
my daughters we learned so much and now
we have an opportunity to take that and
move forward and say you know what we're
so grateful for the last five years how
do we make the next five years better
because of lessons learned so i'm in a
great place i'm so grateful for where
god in in
in in the light has really put me in and
i'm really looking forward
mostly to see how my girls keep
developing
[Music]
you